[Musique]
non c'est jamais arrivé dans l'histoire
du monde que la technologie avance avec
telle vitesse est le résultat c'est que
toutes les structures sociales mondiale
sont bouleversés
il j'adore ce bloc on puisse continuer
c'est ça le sujet siècle c'est là qu'on
peut pas continuer comme ça que ça ne va
pas continuer comme ça
quoi se raconte nos dirigeants quelques
particuliers
rien à faire l'humanité va dans le mur
et on n'y peut rien et ça c'est le genre
de considération des chapeaux publique
complète
[Musique]
plus de productivisme vous considérez ce
ne peut pas guérir les maux d'une prise
servir les mondiaux sous
[Musique]
et je suis pas pour l'apocalypse pour la
collecte pour la catastrophe en espagne
ça je dis simplement voilà quelle était
la situation est très simple nous
avaient une quantité finie de ressources
et ses
7,7 quantité finie elle sera un moment
ou un autre qu'on saurait
[Musique]
c'est beaucoup de controverses ignorent
qu'ils n'ont pas du tout ça va
s'arranger
l'homme s'en est toujours tirée ça c'est
le raisonnement toxiques on a toujours
trouvé des solutions on va sentir et
donc des gentilles
parler d'épuissement se trompent
[Musique]
la contre offre un contrôle assez lent
mais je crois que c'est pas vrai nous
sommes dans une situation jamais vue on
peut pas dire comme ça est toujours
tirée aujourd'hui c'est pas vrai
[Musique]
et teigneux riz seront aggravées par la
science la technologie que votre rêve de
ce qu'on pense
est donc décédé c'est vrai mais ce qui
est arrivé c'est que la machine s'est
emballée
personne n'aurait pensé que l'enfant
j'avais votre âge
personne ne pensait que la machine à
espionner
[Musique]
oui je sortirai du ce monde pour
l'action n'est pas la seule
[Musique]